les derniers vestiges d'Halloween
trônent encore et pourtant c'est une
toute autre ambiance qui s'est installée
à la ferme de Gally guirlandes et
lumière le prouvent Noël est à
l'approche
[Musique]
comme chaque année la ferme propose tous
les samedis et dimanche après-midi de
nombreux ateliers à l'occasion de son
événement Noël et merveille pour 13,5
euros les enfants peuvent s'initier à la
boulangerie et à la confection de
décoration de Noël tout en côtoyant les
animaux de la ferme c'est une petite
couronne voilà ils ont fait une petite
couronne
raphia où ils ont dû créer composer
voilà donc on nous fournit le matériel
et il compose comme ils veulent un petit
sapin elle a collé elle a mis des
petites guirlandes des plumes et une
rondelles d'orange une atmosphère
féerique voulue par l'équipe et qui fait
le bonheur de toute la famille une
ambiance un peu chaleureuse avec les
deux corps lumineux l'esprit un peu de
Noël on se retrouve on partage un bon
moment et puis les enfants repart
surtout avec quelque chose à la maison
pour pour montrer aux personnes qui
n'ont pas pu venir avec eux et puis
surtout pour mettre un peu de déco chez
eux je voulais faire une activité avec
mes enfants en plus qui
rappelle Noël donc c'était parfait et
si on est à Paris donc on est aussi
content de sortir un petit peu de voilà
de Paris et de faire un petit activité
voilà en plein air faire profiter des
activités à ma petite fille qui a 3 ans
et lui montrer les belles décorations de
Noël ça leur permet de voir de faire
d'autres choses et donner des idées
aussi aux parents de sortir crêpes et
jus de pomme chaud à la cannelle vous
attendent à la ferme de Gally une
activité à retrouver jusqu'au 18
décembre
[Musique]